good evening and thank you for joining
us i'm trey gowdy and it's sunday night
in america mark twain famously said the
report of my death was an exaggeration
so too in politics in 2008 president
barack obama swept into office with
majorities in the house and the senate
it was the end of the republican party
they said the party must change
political obituaries were written and
then two years later president obama
lost the house and then four years later
he lost the house and the senate
in 2016 president donald trump won the
presidency and had majorities in both
the house and the senate four years
later republicans were out and democrats
controlled everything
the good thing about democracy is
there's always another election on the
horizon if passed is prologue election
night in 2022
will be a long one for democrats history
tells us that polling currently tells us
that
the democrats are facing several
headwinds the pandemic is still here the
economy is sputtering the supply chain
is backlogged people are concerned about
the border and crime and education
we know from history what's likely to
happen in the midterms the question is
why does it always seem to happen do
political parties overread election
results i mean that seems true right now
democrats control the senate but only
because they control the tiebreaker if
not for joe manchin and kirsten cinema
democrats wouldn't control the senate at
all in fact
if not for a poor performance in two
georgia senate races democrats wouldn't
control the senate
how much of a mandate can you have if
your power comes from a senator in west
virginia
a state where biden didn't win a single
solitary county i mean seriously how
much of the biden agenda do you think
west virginia wants to see implemented
perhaps the american people like checks
and balances perhaps we like
change or perhaps this is how people
respond when political parties forget
about them they create legislative chaos
history and current polling suggest
we're headed back toward legislative
gridlock
in the fall of 2022
the question is will those currently in
power finally figure out the american
people want competence
not transformation they want a better
america not a different america
americans have more in common with joe
manchin and kirsten cinema than they do
the squad
even if the media doesn't
will republicans put their differences
and ambitions aside long enough to let
history and the american people restore
balance
or will georgia repeat itself hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else